the political winds changed here at the
last election
for almost three decades labour held on
to the seat of heinbern in east
lancashire
but now labour finds itself with an
uphill struggle to get it back
my my whole family's been labor
supported always for the working class
and
it just didn't seem like that this time
donna greenwood voted for the
conservative mp here in 2019 helping to
turn the seat blue
she's still happy with her choice have
you have they got you
at the moment are you uh are you are you
still a fan
yeah at the moment yeah you know
i'm not sure i'd have got as much
government funding
if labour has still been in the
government grants have been a godsend
yeah they've been a lifeline to me
kierstama needs to reset expectations
the last decade of failed conservative
ideology
and the last year of our collective
suffering
demands that we now create a new
more secure future in a few weeks time
we'll have a budget that will offer a
simple choice a fork in the road
labor would choose a different path
a path that is focused on the long term
that tackles inequality you've defaulted
today to familiar arguments about tories
underfunding public services
embracing austerity and increasing
inequality
those arguments didn't win labour three
general elections and lost strongholds
like accrington where i am today
what makes you think that this case will
work better this time i think there's a
duty now as we face the future
uh to be honest about the choices that
are before us
as we come out of this do we want to go
back and try to repair what we had
before
or do we move forward to a better and
different economy
and i think this is a moral and
political choice
that we now have to make but people like
donna made their choice
and for now it seems hard to come back
from we've had almost a year of
kierstarma
is he a sort of attractive figure to you
politically what do you what do you see
when you when you look at him
i don't know kierstama understands that
people like her
haven't noticed a great deal of what
he's been doing that's the point of
today's speech to try and
correct that his message to them
no more automatic support from labour
for the government
not just constructive opposition
but will this really be remembered as
the no more mr nice guy moment
have you kind of come across much to do
with kiss dharma do you think
you know has he made any impact on you
were tall as labour leader
do you think you might vote labour in
the future or do you think
um possibly labour and kiss thomas
could get your vote back if the promise
is
bold enough and big enough to make
things better yeah yeah
is he a strong character is he something
he wins he wants obviously he's um
he's going to be a good interrogator
because it's his job to be a you're
a qc right now yeah but does he have any
ideas that's yeah
you need somebody who has some fresh
ideas
ideas and a vision needed as labour
still
trail the tories in the polls sam coates
sky news
akronton east lancashire